[Musica]
quando ero una bambina e mio padre mi ha
fatto promettere di coltivare la
certezza che la vita e l'arte
dell'incontro è che Nulla succede per
caso ogni incontro nella nostra vita Un
senso un significato anche quelli di cui
ti pentirai amaramente mi ha detto anche
quelli di cui capirai il profondo senso
soltanto tanti anni dopo una cosa è
certa nel giardino dell'esistenza noi
possiamo potenziarci o depotenziarci
influenzarci positivamente o
negativamente a rafforzarci e
indebolirci e Tutto dipenderà dalla
dall'afflato e dall'ispirazione dai
quali ti lascerai colmare quindi piccola
mia abbi cura dei germogli che vedrai
spuntare sugli alberi che sorgeranno nel
giardino della tua vita perché Tutto
dipenderà davvero dalla cura che
metterai e dal significato profondo di
ogni incontro che avrai mio padre
ascoltava moltissima musica jazz e io
già amavo Miles Davis incontrarlo e
poter dialogare con lui era uno dei miei
più grandi ultimi giorni e con lui tutti
quei grandi musicisti che sono in grado
di toccare con il loro talento le corde
dell'interiorità Mi era già chiaro il
senso è lassioma che se noi ascoltiamo
buona musica diventiamo esseri umani
migliori e mi era già chiaro il senso
del silenzio come vero linguaggio
dell'anima non è un caso infatti che io
consideri grandi maestri buddisti e
Rockstar come miei maestri come i miei
insegnanti ho iniziato a praticare
Buddismo proprio nello stesso periodo in
cui è cominciata la mia carriera e
nonostante io possa comprendere che
questa mia affermazione possa fare
storcere il naso a molti Ecco io vi
assicuro che musicisti è maestri
buddisti hanno moltissime cose in comune
per esempio la capacità di anticipare i
tempi per esempio la capacità di sentire
e percepire prima degli altri per
esempio la capacità di creare modelli di
fiducia profonda e soprattutto di
profonda libertà
Se la vita è l'arte dell'incontro e
Nulla succede per caso Noi oggi siamo
qui per influenzarci e sicuramente
positivamente e allora composizioni
scomposizioni voglio portarvi
all'interno di alcuni germogli che sono
sbocciati in maniera inaspettata ma in
maniera meravigliosa e attraverso alcune
composizioni scomposizioni voglio
raccontare una parte della mia biografia
che mi auguro possa essere di
ispirazione per le persone che stanno
ascoltando Allora la prima lezione che
ho imparato è non si può amare nulla che
non si rispetti e questa è una frase che
ha detto revisankar il grande sitarista
indiano a George Harrison durante una
mattina in cui revisanka stava dando
lezioni di sitar al grande chitarrista
dei Beatles ad un certo punto è
squillato il telefono George Harrison ha
posato malamente il sitare è andato a
rispondere quando è rientrato revisankar
ha detto vedi George tu può essere anche
il più grande chitarrista del mondo se
il chitarrista dei Beatles Ma se non
metti Cure attenzione nei piccoli gesti
della quotidi modella Come accendere un
incenso appoggiare un sitar tu non
potrai dire di aver vissuto la vita
appieno e noi oggi che vita viviamo
siamo sempre più distratti siamo sempre
più frammentati con i nostri pensieri
siamo sempre su più fronti siamo sempre
di corsa siamo la prima generazione
apparsa sul pianeta ad essere la più
sovrastimolata e infatti siamo anche più
stanchi perché il suono penetra la
nostra corteccia cerebrale Siamo
circondati da badge notifiche suoni
musica non scelta Eppure sarvam a Nam si
dice in sanscrito tutto È cibo e quindi
chiederci cosa ci nutre nel profondo al
di là di quello che ci alimenta dovrebbe
essere una domanda cruciale nella vita
di ognuno di noi diciamo tutti di amare
la musica e tutti mettiamo dei grancuori
è il nostro lessico diciamo di amare le
cose ma quante queste cose che diciamo
di amare in realtà le rispettiamo
veramente vi ricordate non si può amare
nulla che non si rispetti
Allora io trovo che questo sia molto
interessante perché tutti mi dicono Io
amo la musica Ebbene voglio darvi una
notizia la musica adesso dappertutto nei
supermercati negli ascensori e nei
centri commerciali la musica non è più
scelta la musica non è più
cercata la musica non è più veramente
Ascoltata non siamo neanche più in grado
di riconoscerla addirittura noi
scarichiamo la musica abbiamo l'ardire
di non pagare la musica Eppure ci
dichiariamo dei grandi intenditori di
musica Ecco la cattiva notizia che avere
quattro brani scaricati 4000 brani
scaricati sul vostro computer non fa di
voi di aver intenditori di musica perché
l'ascolto della musica con attenzione è
fondamentalmente prodromo ed ed è
propedeutico per un ascolto nei
confronti di noi stessi e per questo che
la meditazione il silenzio della
meditazione è l'ascolto attento della
musica hanno la capacità di farci
volgere lo sguardo dall'esterno
all'interno che cosa succederebbe se non
centro commerciale per esempio anziché
musica dozzinale composta al luogo per
distrarre per favorire un tipo di
consumismo
distratto omologato senza
fondamentalmente nessun fondamento
venisse diffusa musica classica ve lo
siete mai chiesto
la gente smetterebbe di comprare e
sapete perché perché la musica classica
è la musica creata secondo una certa
urgenza creativa ancora una volta porta
lo sguardo dall'esterno all'interno e ci
fa fare delle domande importanti ci fa
porre delle domande Come chi siamo Chi
sto diventando Che tipo di contributo
voglio dare a questo mondo e ci fa
Formula una domanda come is this the
life really want composizione e
scomposizione numero 2 Questo è il
titolo di un bellissimo album di Roger
Waters il grande leader dei Pink Floyd
ed è una domanda che gli ho fatto quando
ho avuto
l'immenso onore di passare una giornata
con lui a New York e di poter disquisire
con lui di tantissime cose che
riguardano l'essere umano perché dovete
sapere che Roger Waters oltre essere il
leader dei Pink Floyd anche un attento
conoscitore dell'animo umano non è un
caso che sia il compositore di the dog
side of the moon il perfetto disco con
il quale farà l'amore ma soprattutto un
compendio di psicoterapia
Repubblica e lui mi ha detto che l'unica
soluzione che intravede per poter vivere
una vita veramente appieno è quella di
riappropriarci di un senso di
responsabilità che abbiamo gli uni nei
confronti degli altri ed è per questo
che lui nonostante la sua età ormai è un
signore adulto Eppure rimane
estremamente sexy continua a portare la
sua musica in giro per il mondo perché
attraverso la sua musica vuole portare
le persone a investigare il senso di
empatia e attraverso il senso di empatia
comprendere che apparteniamo tutti ad
una grande famiglia che è la grande
famiglia umana
Ora noi ci illudiamo di scegliere le
persone per il loro aspetto fisico non
fondamentalmente scegliamo le persone
per la loro energia e Laura di Roger
Waters fosse assicurarvi che è immensa è
meravigliosa Lui parlava e io potevo
rivedere tutta la mia vita Lui parlava
io rilanciavo sulla mia traiettoria
esistenziale Volevo anch'io fare
qualcosa di straordinario le sue parole
in qualche modo mi ispiravano ad essere
la migliore versione di me stessa e così
sono rientrate in Italia e ho fondato
una piattaforma di condivisione
basata sui pilastri di responsabilità
resilienza e fedeltà a se stessi dove
invito le persone ad un dialogo per
farci delle domande per porci delle
domande per comprendere che tipo di
esseri umani vogliamo diventare ci
insegnano qualsiasi tipo di professione
ma non ci insegnano a vivere il mondo
con Maggiore competenza
E allora non sarebbe meraviglioso se a
fine anno anziché chiederci quanti soldi
abbiamo fatturato ci venisse chiesto
anche cosa abbiamo fatto per appartenere
alla categoria esseri umani Senza
considerare che in inglese umanità si
dice Human kinds e quindi la gentilezza
dovrebbe essere alla base dovrebbe
essere la cifra stilistica con la quale
noi camminiamo nel mondo la gentilezza
nei nostri stessi confronti e nei
confronti di tutto quanto il creato
perché giocare in piccolo non aiuta il
mondo e questa è una bellissima frase La
mia scomposizione numero 3 che mi è
stata detta da Lou Reed lorienderson
quando li ho incontrati all'inizio della
mia carriera Lou Reed lorienderson che
persona a dir poco straordinarie due
geni dell'avanguardia due persone
profondamente Human profondamente
empatiche profondamente compassionevoli
e mi hanno detto vedi Paola il successo
più bello il successo più profondo è
quello che deriva da seguire alla
propria autenticità da seguire il
proprio cuore il mondo ha bisogno di
ispirazione sincera e di coraggio non di
modestia e qui c'è un altro punto io ho
intervistato più di 1.300 grande artiste
Rockstar e posso assicurarvi che nessuno
di loro è modesto ma sono umili anche a
costo di esperienze profondamente
dolorose come quella di Lou Reed che a
16 anni è stato sottoposta
all'elettroshock perché voleva giocare
in grande in un ambiente familiare
sociale che lo voleva piccolo ristretto
omologato
Eppure se ci pensate neanche
l'elettroshock è riuscito a spostare Lou
Reed dalla sua traiettoria di splendore
neanche l'elettroshock è riuscito a
spostare Lou Reed dal suo ikigai dal suo
Dharma e quella traiettoria di splendore
dovrebbe essere appannaggio di tutti gli
esseri umani e sapete perché perché noi
siamo un miracolo per definizione Noi
siamo il prodotto il frutto di un ovulo
e di uno tra 200 milioni di spermatozoi
non dovrebbe già essere questo il motivo
per avere una traiettoria di splendore
nella propria vita
c'è un'altra scomposizione che ha
formato veramente il mio pensiero è che
mi è stata detta da Patti Smith e cioè
che essere Punk non significa avere i
capelli con la cresta e non significa
avere i capelli colorati bensì pensare
con la propria testa e per pensare con
la propria testa bisogna sfilarsi dalla
logica dell'Iper produttività dobbiamo
ritornare a sentire perché nel momento
in cui mi ritorniamo a sentire capiamo
veramente che vita vogliamo avere e mi
sono ricordata di questa frase durante
lo stop forzato del covip tre mesi
chiusa in casa e mi sono riappropriata
di un sogno di un sogno che avevo che
avevo formulato a me stessa nel 2009
quando sono stata nominata dalla
Commissione Europea Come ambasciatrice
per un nuovo protocollo sul clima al
Coffee Tina al suo medico Ebbene sotto
quel cielo terzo e progressista ancora
una volta ho deciso che volevo uscire
dalla mia zona di comfort e volevo fare
parte della soluzione non del problema
quell'esperienza
davvero cambiato la mia rotta
esistenziale e così sono rientrati in
Italia e con mio padre che Allora aveva
79 anni e mio figlio di 3 anni e mezzo
per un anno abbiamo deciso di fare un
viaggio all'interno del nostro ruolo di
consumatori perché oggigiorno siamo
sempre più consumatori e sempre meno
esseri umani
Ebbene È stata un'esperienza veramente
straordinaria per un anno abbiamo
vissuto senza frigorifero senza
contatore senza riscaldamento senza
acqua calda e Durante quel periodo
veramente ho capito che è fondamentale
comprendere che ogni nostro gesto nostro
ogni acquisto hanno un impatto
sull'ambiente e quando era a Copenaghen
sotto quel cielo terso e progressista e
vedevo queste nuvole che dalla
Danimarca andavano verso la Svezia io ho
sognato un giorno di trasferirmi in
Svezia un paese dove ancora la calma e
la lentezza sono dei valori perché era
arrivato per me il momento visto che
scrivo libri sulla sostenibilità da
tempi non sospetti appunto dal 2005 dal
2009 volevo sperimentare un nuovo tipo
di sostenibilità la sostenibilità
dell'anima è così mi sono ricordata di
quell'altra frase che mi è stata detta
daiggy Pop Jump and the bridgewater il
grande padre del Punk mi disse questa
frase e aveva ragione l'essenza pura del
Punk salta e il ponte apparirà e così in
tre mesi ho venduto tutto quello che
possedevo in Italia e mi sono trasferita
in Svezia con mio figlio siamo passati
da 200 metri quadrati nel cuore di
Milano a 11 metri quadrati nel cuore di
Malmo ma tutte le mattine io avevo
saltato andavo a cercare quel ponte e
quel ponte lo andava a cercare di fronte
alla casa nei miei sogni una casa tutta
di vetri di fronte al Mar Baltico dalla
quale avrei potuto guidare le mie
meditazioni Perché nel frattempo quella
piattaforma che ho fondato quando sono
rientrato dal mio viaggio a New York con
Roger Waters ora conta migliaia di
persone che attraverso la meditazione e
attraverso l'auto osservazione hanno
deciso di avere un passo più lieve sul
mondo e sicuramente un passo più
assertivo chiedevo a mio figlio di
sederci di fronte a quell'appartamento e
di desiderare di essere già dentro
quell'appartamento di vedersi lì dentro
quell'appartamento di sentire già la
nostra vita svedese
scorre nelle nostre vene e così le
stelle si sono Allineate e abbiamo
affittato quella casa che è la nostra
casa dove viviamo oggi e tutte le
mattine per ringraziare mi immergo nel
Mar Baltico che è freddo freddissimo ma
voglio imparare a stare comoda nella
scomodità
è davvero tutte le mattine mi ribattezzo
a nuova vita perché noi ogni giorno
possiamo rinascere a nuova vita non è un
caso che le prime parole del Sutra del
Loto siano Nigi Dora in poi ogni giorno
possiamo compiere un atto battesimale
per una nuova esistenza e allora ho
capito molto più profondamente la
promessa che mi aveva fatto fare Mio
padre quando era una bambina Sì
la vita è l'arte dell'incontro è vero ma
soprattutto
dell'incontro con se stessi Grazie